خلال اسبوع واحد ارتفعت كل الاسعار في
لبنان بشكل هستيري مع تسجيل سعر صرف
الدولار رقما قياسيا جديدا وهو 56 الف
ليره لبنانيه جنون الاسعار هذا انعكس
بطبيعه الحال على اسعار المحروقات لتتخطى
المليون ليره ثمن الصفيحه
[موسيقى]
عشر الاف
وهو صغير لاي خطوط انقاذيه واصلاحيه افلس
اللبنانيون من حلول الكفاح المعيشي ليعود
الشارع مقصدهم الى مصر في لبنان الوجهه
الاساسيه للمتظاهرين عند كل استحقاق مالي
حضر عدد من المواطنين وقطعوا الطريق
احتجاجا وبعد حوالي ساعتين غادروا انشغالا
بهمومهم اليوميه من تبعات الازمه اسباب
انهيار العمله كثيره وطال ما هذه الاسباب
موجوده فلا سقفه للانهيار
رئيس جمهوريه ما فيه حكومه
عاجزين بنك مركزي ومصارف ما عندهم
احتياطات اجنبيه قضاء
معطل او عاجز كمان او منقسم بدليل قصه
انفجار المرفق كلها العوامل كابيتال
كونترول
منقرضت واتفاق مع صندوق النقد الدولي كمان
منقر ومتى منع شراء الدولارات من لبنان
الى سوريا
المستشار المالي لحزب الله حسن مقلد الذي
ادرج ضمن العقوبات الامريكيه مؤخرا لعب
دوره في هذا لانهيار
مقلد يا اللي بتقول وزاره الخزانه انه
عندها همم
بنشاط ما يلي بتسهل نشاط مالي لحزب الله
وخصوصا اليوم كمان في معلومات بتقول انه
صار عم بلم دولارات من السوق
الليره
الشرائيه وغلائي كافه السلع والخدمات من
تبيعات الازمه ولا حله بحسب المراقبين الا
بانجاز الاتفاقي مع صندوق النقد الدولي
ناهد يوسف العربيه بيروت